الكثير من التطورات شهدها تويتر بعد نحوي
10 ايام فقط من استحواذ ايلون ماسك على
الموقع المنصه اليوم تواجه ازمه قد تصف
بخطه ملياردير طموح الازمه يمكن اختصارها
بكلمتين هروب المعلنين شركات كبرى استجابه
لضغوطات المنظمات الحقوقيه وعلقت
اعلاناتها مؤقتا على تويتر وذلك لحين
معرفه اتجاهات المنصه في ظل الاداره
الجديده ومدى تسامحها مع محتويات الكراهيه
والمعلومات المضلله او فصل الموظفين لا
يساعد ويشكركوا في النوايا المنصه بالفعل
تشهد تراجع عن هائلا من حيث الارادات
والمستخدمون يهددون بالتغريد في مكان اخر
وسط هذه الفوضى مصر على فرد ثمانيه
دولارات رسوم شهريه مقابل الاحتفال بعلامه
التوثيق الزرقاء ماسك يريد تقليل اعتماد
تويتر على الاعلانات والتي تمثل 90% من
اجمالي ايرادات من الصعب لكن انه يحتاج
الى الوقت على
424 الف حساب موثق على تويتر لكن هذا
العدد قد ينخفضه كثيرا خلال الاشهر
المقبله قرار ماسك بوضع رسوم مقابل توثيق
الحسابات قبل برفض كبير البعض يرى ان هذه
الرسوم ستجعل من تويتر منصه طبقيه من يملك
العلامه وحده هو من يملك القوه وعرض
القرار الكثير من المشاهير الكاتب
الامريكي ستيفن كينج اعترض على دفع 20
دولارا مقابل الاحتفاظ بالتوثيق وقال انه
مستعد لمغادره المنصه بعدها قرر باسك ان
يخفض القيمه الى ثمانيه دولارات الكسندريا
كورتيز نائبه الكونجرس قالت اتعجب من
ملياردير يحاول الترويجه لفكره ان حريه
التعبير تساوي ثمانيه دولارات رسوم اشتراك
شهريه وبعد يوم من التغريده قالت ان ماسك
حسابها لان كلامها لم يعجب
ايضا شون دارينز مبتكره مسلسل لجريزا
اناتومي كتبت في تغريده مقتضبه غير موافقه
على اي مما يخطط له الى الماسك وداعا
المغنيه الامريكيه سارا باريس كتبت لقد
كان موقع تويتر ممتعا وداعا اراكم في منصه
اخرى
[موسيقى]
وفي فقره الجانب الاقتصادي تنضم الينا
وتنورنا في الاستديو كما جرت العاده
الاعلام
هل تتوقعين ان يتراجع ماسك عن فرض الرسوم
على علامه التوثيقه مبدئيا
التوفيق العلامه الزرقاء يعني بدايه كانت
شائعات وكنا مترددين حتى انا من الاشخاص
اللي قلت لا ما اعتقد لانه لما سووا
شو يسموه طال يعني همم
تقريبا لمليون ونصف شخص 80% من الاشخاص
قالوا انهم لم يدفعوا مقابل ذلك يعني كيف
او التوثيق يعني هي حريه التعبير صارت
بفلوس منهم زملاءنا كثير همم
من الواضح حسب ما قرات انه هذا
الفيريفيكيشن او البلوتيك علامه الزرقاء
ستمح مو بس للمشاهير لاي شخص يدفع ثمانيه
دولاراتي ممكن قد تساعد هذه الخطوه في
فعلا همم تنظيف همم تويتر من الحسابات
الوهميه لانه لما حيتم الدفع عن طريق نظام
ابل او عن طريق نظام جوجل الاندرويد او
الاي يو اس لما تحطي كريديت كارد حييتم
التحقق من شخصيتك واكيد هيكون شخص حقيقي
مو بوت فبالتالي سوف يساعد فعلا في عمليه
ستكون علامه التوثيق الزرقاء متاحه لجميع
الاشخاص الحقيقي
لجميع الاشخاص يعني ممكن يكون عندك ممكن
يكون عندك مليون بس هل سيدفعون هناك 80%
من اصل مليون ونصف قالوا انهم لن يقوموا
بالدفع يعني هي الخمس دولارات اللي كانت
حطتها تويتر
سبسكرايب عشان النظام الازرق ما كانت
الناس تدفعها يمكن الشركات اللي تمنح
خصوصا شركات الاعلام اللي تمنح موظفيها
هذه البلوتوث ممكن ان تقوم هي شركه بدفع
بس الاشخاص كاشخاص يعني من من الصعب حتى
الكثير من المشاهير ايضا هناك اربع مشاهير
مؤخرا انسحبوا من تويتر من غير المشاكل
اليوم اللي هي على المحتوى وصومعه المحتوى
غير اللائق والتعليقات اللي فيها
ديسكريمنيشن يعني تفرقه عنصريه غير عن هذا
الموضوع طبعا هذا ايضا جانب اخر ادى الى
انسحاب العديد من المشروع
ما هي التحديثات المقرره
اليوم مره اخرى جدا متاثر هو
يعني حاطط في راسه لهم ماسك حط في راسه
همم تيك توك فيقول لك بما انه هذا الفيديو
نجحت على التيك توك لازم تنجح واريد
اسويها احسن بعدين الفيديو هذا القصيره
اللي موجود على تيك توك احتمال كبير ترجع
اللي هي الفيديوهات القصيره مثل اللي على
التيك توك على الانستغرام
سوف يكون هناك مساحه اكثر بس المخيف انه
هذه التغييرات جاءت اليوم قبل انتخابات
التجديد النصفي لمجلس الشيوخ يعني ما بقى
يمكن الثلاثاء هي هتكون واجا هذا التجديد
والتحديث وحريه او المزيد من حريه التعبير
قبل الانتخابات فالعديد يشكون بنوايا الى
المسرحيهم بهذا الموضوع طيب هناك على
شركات عالميه خافت
انسحابه من تويتر مشاهير كبار من تويتر لو
يعدد خسائر تويتر
اليوم 90% من هذه الارادات تاتي من
الاعلانات غير اللي قلنا عن الجلوس
اليوم هذه الاعلانات انسحبت لوريال انسحبت
جنرال موتورز هناك شركه اسمها انتر بابليك
هي احلى اكبر المجموعات الاعلانيه هناك
همم مثلا مجموعات مدنيه تضغط على شركات
مثل كوكاكولا وامازون لازاله اعلاناتها من
على تويتر بسبب المحتوى غير اللائق الذي
لا يناسب مجتمع على تويتر فهذه كلها اليوم
تتعرض لضغوط احتماليه ان تنسحب ايضا لهم
ماسك برر انه بسبب هذه المجموعات اللي
تضغط على المعلنين بسبب هذه المجموعات هو
اليوم يطرد العديد من الموظفين لانه اليوم
تويتر يخسر اربعه منذ ان استلم لهم ماسك
الاداره يخسر اربعه ملايين دول يوميا من
العوائد منذ ان استلم لهم ماسك الاداره
بسبب انسحاب المعلنين شكرا